a front-runner for young Han Solo has
been chosen and he looks more like
Leonardo DiCaprio
oh well close enough I'm Kate and this
is your don't get cocky news update the
Han Solo movie has lined up to be the
second standalone Star Wars spin-off
following this year's rogue one the film
has a script directors and release date
but lacks one thing han himself it has
now been reported that rising star Alden
Ehrenreich is the frontrunner to play
the young space smuggler
according to Deadline Aaron Reich's
impressive screen tests have put him
ahead of the other actors under
consideration last month it was reported
that the casting process had narrowed to
Ehrenreich Jack Raina from transformers
age of extinction and Taron Egerton from
Kingsman the Secret Service the Han Solo
film is to be directed by jump street
phil lord and Christopher Miller from a
script by star wars veteran lawrence
kasdan
and his son john although the movie is
yet to be given a title it has been
confirmed that Chewbacca will also play
a part in the story that is currently
set for May 2018 movies do you think
Ehrenreich is a good choice or do you
have someone else in mind let me know in
the comments all come and find me on
twitter i'm at how not to draw thanks
for watching and for all your gaming and
entertainment news he became spot
[Music]